welcome back ladies and gents today
we're going to talk about gargantuar on
the vergis planet which is an action
adventure sci-fi anime series well then
should we begin humans have left earth
to make a paradise in space named avalon
as humanity's new home creating the
galactic alliance of humankind
mollusk-like live forms known as hideous
appeared as a threat before the galactic
alliance and a war rages between them
rmc ledo with his mech chamber k-6821
joins the latest attack against the
hideous the attack eventually ends in
failure and a retreat order is issued by
leto's commanding officer however ledo's
unable to return and is cast out into
space six months later the crew members
of the salvage ship gargantia retrieve
chamber from the bottom of the ocean but
are unable to take it apart after
everyone leaves ledo decides to explore
and examine his current location only to
be noticed by a young man named pinion
the head of the repairman leto kidnaps a
courier named amy as he's chasing his
corner on a pylon by the entire crew he
finds out that he's on a habitable
planet which shocks him enough to
release abi then he summons chamber who
confirms that this is the planet of
humanity's origin ledo stays pinned on
the pylon and attempts to open a
friendly dialogue with the fleet
commander's assistant while chamber
translates voletto and surprises the
crew members by being an unmanned
machine after the assistant discusses
with the other crew members what to do
with leto amy visits her bedridden
younger brother to give him a small
ship's wheel to complete his model ship
amy later approaches leto with fish to
eat as a friendship ritual she explains
that this planet called earth was once
frozen over and some humans chose to
stay the ice eventually melted and
became a vast ocean in which many people
form fleets to salvage old technology
from below looking for other items of
advanced technology the commander's
assistant sends redhead hottie the
leader of the excavation team to the
point where chamber and ledo were found
but her ship is attacked by pirates amy
asks leto to help them and he agrees
with the intention of earning their
trust letter boards chamber and
efficiently kills the pirates with no
harm to the hottie ship and crew as amy
and the others watch in shock at
chambers destructive power
amy disapproves of leto's actions and
the leaders of the gargantia discuss the
eventual retaliation they may suffer the
redhead girl brings amy to talk with
ledo and they explain to him the weapons
must only be used as a last resort as
people must rely on each other to
survive in their world after amy
reconciles with ledo a large pirate flea
led by the pira empress launches an
attack and slowly approaches the
gargantia ledo discusses the situation
with the commander's assistant and
agrees to help them once more in
exchange for being accepted aboard the
fleet instructed to defeat the enemies
with no casualties leto disables the
pirate ships in the front lines and
returns to the gargantia to deal with a
sneak attack led by pirate empress
herself piloting her custom
humanoid-shaped mech called the surfing
lobster ledo battles and easily defeats
the pirate empress forcing them to flee
upon being saluted by the crew of the
gargantia ledo is greeted by amy and
replies by thanking her the first native
expression that he'd learned later
letter receives an invoice to pay for
his collateral damage although the
commander's assistant says that he
should be relieved from the living
expenses and the fee of having chamber
aboard while chamber helps the others
work leno is seen sculpting the hidey
house claw that he always carries with
him he gives it to amy who plans to pass
it to her brother later during the day
she takes our mc to see the resident
doctor who explains to him that most of
humankind's old technology is lost thus
it's impossible for the gargantia to
help him return to space after they go
to amy's brother who asks leto about his
life in space it soon starts to rain a
little and leto helps collect rainwater
to replenish the fleet's fresh water
supply amy's brother realizes that ledo
was actually carving a flute as the
little boy plays it leder recalls a long
forgotten memory that makes him cry
after asking the kid to return the flute
to him our mc later wonders if he should
learn more about their surroundings
while chamber mentions that he must
eventually leave it all behind when
returning to his unit ledo takes up work
as a fisherman but he finds himself
unable to pilot a diver mech and sends
chamber to assist the other fishermen
instead since chambers rather messy with
his capture of fish let her board's
chambered to help the other fishermen
properly obtain a nice catch using large
nets later that night amy spent some
time alone with ledo and the two become
closer the following day he does some
salvage work with the red-haired girl
and things go smoothly until an
underwater creature appears as chamber
identifies it as a hideous ledo abandons
his work to confront it he kills the
creature known as a whale squid
considered a sacred animal on the planet
and news of his death spread rumors of
an impending misfortune towards the
gargantia pinyin plans to draft leto
into his crew in order to explore the
uncharted whale squid territory and
salvage its treasures but the redhead
girl tries to deter him after chamber
analyzes that whale squid are indeed
similar to the hidey house leno is
determined to exterminate them all
despite amy and her brother attempting
to change his mind earlier when a huge
number of whale squid are seen
approaching the gargantia fleet
commander orders a temporary shutdown on
all machinery and lights to prevent any
provocation as the whale squid pass
under the gargantia leto ignores amy
when she tries to stop him from fighting
the whale squid but he's forced to stand
down when commander's assistant points a
gun at him until all the whale squid
pass under without any incident the
commander is informed by opinion of his
plan and the ship commander flange
declares his intention to accompany
opinion with his ship as both expressed
their objective to secede from the
gargantia the commander tries to
dissuade them until he suffers a heart
attack before his death he appoints his
assistant as his successor meanwhile
chamber informs letto that he finally
managed to pinpoint the location of
their civilization in space but it may
take thousands of years until someone
picks up their distress signal due to
their current location on earth as the
commander's funeral is held several
ships agreed to follow opinion's plan
and prepare themselves to secede from
the gargantia seeing how much his sister
is suffering with ledo's decision to
leave amy's brother tries to discourage
him from leaving however leto says that
his drive to kill the whale squid also
comes from his desire to protect both
amy and him from the hidey house soon
after a devastated amy watches as the
ship leaves the gargantia with ledo
aboard them leto starts his offensive on
the whale squid nest assisted by
pinion's crew and their barrage of depth
charges obliterating the enemies without
much effort opinion remembers he
witnessed his older brother being killed
by whale squid during a failed mission
to find treasure while investigating an
ancient facility leto finds some records
in a storage box on accessing them he
learns that the hideous were once humans
who underwent heavy genetic
modifications to adapt themselves to a
space environment calling themselves
evolvers viewing their efforts as
blasphemy a faction of humankind
declared war on them leading to their
current conflict after both sides
abandoned earth during the fifth ice age
except for the ancestors to the current
humans and whale squid living on the
planet devastated by this revelation
ledo shouts in despair when chambers
slays a hideo's child with his
permission with all the hideaws in the
area killed pinyon and his crew managed
to salvage rare ancient technology
however pinyin says that his crew has
the right to keep the technology for
themselves sending a radio broadcast to
other fleets to warn them to keep out of
his cruise territory as this broadcast
reaches the gargantia the fleet's
already reorganized and there's concern
that other ships may leave to join
pinion side using an ancient cannon
pinion forces a crew of hostile pirates
to surrender and join his fleet leto
then questions if there's still a need
to keep fighting the hideos after all
they've learned chamber comes to the
conclusion that the galactic alliance
and the hideous simply cannot co-exist
seeing as one side evolved and perfected
their civilization while the other
relinquished civilization altogether
thus their conflict is inevitable
chamber then informs letto about a
transmission from a galactic alliance
vessel as a huge fleet approaches them
leto sees his commander still alive
inside his machine caliber atop the
vessel the commander contacts ledo and
instructs him to return to active duty
upon reuniting with him leder learns
that his commander is struck with some
disease that doesn't allow him to leave
his cockpit when leto tells him that the
hidears are originally humans his
commander reveals that he always knew
that just like the high command of the
galactic alliance despite that he
insists to fight the hideous at all this
time he was organizing a powerful fleet
within the cult militaristic society in
order to rally all the humans on earth
under them pinion is summoned to ledo's
commander fleet surprised to be taken
there by the pirate empress who's now
working under leto's commander then
pinion is approached by the mech caliber
striker x3752
who offers him a post as an engineer to
repair and develop weapons for the fleet
the rest of his companions are also
forced to join the fleet in separate
apartments sometime later the commander
discusses with ledo the next step of his
plan which is a large-scale operation
much stiletto shock that somehow
involves the gargantia
pinyon is approached by the pirate
empress who's planning a rebellion at
the fleet ledo tries to dissuade his
commander from preparing to attack the
gargantia but he doesn't have success
confused about what he should do leto
witnesses the people of the fleet
throwing their sick and weak into the
ocean realizing that the same will be
done to amy's brother ledo decides to
confront his commander by himself
accepting lelo's decision pinyin equips
chamber with some extra weapons while
the pirate empress and flange make
preparations for the impending uprising
flange's granddaughter is instructed by
leto to deliver a message to the
gargantia however she almost faints by
travelling so far by herself and has to
be rescued by amy informed of the attack
the crew of the gargantia considers to
abandon the fleet as ledo is recommended
instead amy urges that they should do
something to help leto as well and one
of the elders suggests the new commander
to make use of the special key that was
entrusted to her as the rebellion begins
ledo assisted by pinyon's crew fights
his commander while the pirates attack
the fleet soldiers when ledo finally
manages to pin down the commander and
open striker's cockpit it's revealed
that his commander was long dead inside
it striker reached the conclusion that
it was necessary for the humans to view
her as their god to ensure stability of
the fleet both ledo and chamber disagree
with her philosophy and decide to
destroy her ledo merges his nervous
system with chambers interface to
increase chambers capabilities but
risking his life however amy appears
soon after to tell leto that he doesn't
need to fight alone meanwhile at the
gargantia the commander uses the special
key to activate an ancient mass driver
stored inside the main ship using it to
bonfire the enemy fleet pinyon evacuates
his crew aboard the salvage vessel and
intends to destroy both the recovered
relics and striker's followers but is
saved at the last second by the pirate
empress ledo and chamber pursue stryker
when she targets the gargantia despite
living a life of sacrifice as a soldier
ledo truly desires to survive and live
with amy chamber then relieves ledo from
duty and ejects him to safety before
destroying striker in a suicide attack
some time later letter has become an
experienced excavator in the wales
square territory and is also in a
relationship with amy that being said we
hope we fulfilled our purpose by making
you entertain don't forget to like
subscribe maybe share and comment until
next time fellas